hey everyone welcome to see each at
hosted by cloud on air which hosts live
webinars every Tuesday about Google
cloud my name is Stephanie Wong cloud
customer engineer and today I'm super
excited to introduce you all to Ryan
Frizzle who is a networking specialist
and customer engineer here at Google
cloud as well so Ryan did you want to
introduce yourself really quickly sure
it's Stephanie said I'm uh Networks me
for Google Club so I spend most my time
talking to customers about all things
cloud networking awesome so just to
remind all the live viewers you can ask
live Q&A throughout the segment on the
cloud on-air platform and we will have
Googlers help answer them throughout and
we'll also have some time at the end for
Q&A as well so without further ado let's
get into it I'm super excited today so
you talked about networking which is
such an important foundational concept
to understand as people begin to think
about moving their workloads to the
cloud especially when they're trying to
map out their on-premise network
topology into something like a
software-defined network on Google Club
so Ryan take it away
sure so networking is obviously a very
broad topic it's not something I can
cover in the next 30 minutes so I want
to lay out a quick roadmap of what you
can expect today
and then follow-on sessions that we have
planned so today I'm going to talk about
the VPC construct or the virtual private
cloud I'm gonna talk about a concept
that Google is has done called shared
VPC and I'm also talk about once you
build these VP sees how do you actually
connect to them from your on-prem or
datacenter locations during the next
section will cover routing or VPC
peering next we'll move into firewalls
and security
we'll also plan to have a session on
load balancers and all the flavors that
Google has and how to use them in the
cloud environment and then we'll cover
other services if there's something that
working related that you want us to
cover please let us know and we'll
figure out how to integrate it into
these topics so with that let's jump
into it so if anybody has done any work
in the cloud this probably looks very
similar to you right this is sort of
it's what I call a traditional VPC so if
you've used AWS you've used other cloud
providers this is sort of how it's built
right so what I'm showing here is two
VPC has been built with two different
subnets so as you know when you build V
pcs in this manner the way that VMs in
say uswest
talked to VMs in u.s. East is typically
through VPN
Gateway right there's no way to actually
have direct communication between say a
web frontend that's sitting in US West
and maybe a web back-end that's sitting
in u.s. deist other than going through
that VPN connection so Google thought
about this topic and said okay how can
we potentially do this different how can
we simplify this and we came up with
Google's version of the virtual private
cloud environment so in Google's world
the VP see the container with which in
the subnets live is actually a global
construct so instead of having to build
you know you VPC and uswest
a vp c and US east of e pc in say amia
you actually build one vp c and then you
actually put subnets in the different
regions within that vp c now as you see
here there's no VPN required to actually
have a vm in uswest
talk to a vm in u.s. East this is all
handled by Google in terms of routing
that we have under the hood so it's
nothing that you have to do now you can
control this through a lot of means
through like firewall rules and bears or
things which we'll talk about in other
sections but really from a conceptual
standpoint it really simplifies the
environment as you're deploying things
so just the highlight that again you're
saying that we don't need a VPN for
traffic between regions how does Google
do this so we do this through Google's
underlying network so this is the same
network that we use to run our search
engine to run YouTube to run Gmail all
that infrastructure that Google has
built for our own use we actually use
that as part of cloud right so we use
that same network infrastructure to move
traffic from let's say you know VM is
running on in u.s. West one to say a VM
running in a me oh wow pretty
revolutionary yeah so really why is this
concept important right so one it
simplifies the network right so as I
said you have one global private
networking space with a regional
segmentation to put yourself that's in
right I talked about the VPNs so if you
look at the picture that I that I
started with it's very simple when
you're dealing with two V pcs and say a
couple projects but imagine expanding
that model to hundreds of projects all
running hundreds of VPNs now you've got
mass amounts of VPNs that you're
building you've got mass amounts of the
VPN gateways that you're trying to
stitch together when you do it with
Google
then you don't need to use a lot of
infrastructure so it really simplifies
that Network stuff which your network
engineers and networking engineering
organization will love that
simplification the same thing applies to
routers so what I didn't show there is
in each of those V pcs you actually have
routers to dynamically advertise routes
so in the traditional environment where
you're building a VP seeing in the West
you're gonna put one two maybe even more
routers in that environment you're going
to put some more routers in the VP see
in the east more routers in amia you're
gonna use those across the VPN tunnels
to provide dynamic advertisements for
your subnets so you can quickly see
you've got a lot of sprawl in terms of
the routers and the BGP sessions you're
managing it tends to grow and grow and
grow on you with Google's construct you
don't need to do that you can actually
put a couple cloud routers in place
right so if you're trying to stitch
together multiple V pcs together you
actually can just use a couple cloud
routers to do it so have these very
large global routing domains and and not
have you know router sprawl we have
hundreds of routers so it really
simplifies just that network
infrastructure component of things
second it simplifies management right so
you can think about if you have all
these VPN gateways if you have all these
VPN tunnels what's happening is when
something breaks you have to go and
figure out what is broken where is it
broken you know you're looking at
potentially different cloud routers
you're looking at different VPN tunnel
just looking at different VPN gateways
you're looking at the a side the C side
because you have all the stuff stitched
together in this very complex mesh
alright with the Google environment it's
much simpler so when something isn't
functioning there's only a few things to
really look at and sort of dissect what
is working and what isn't working right
so it really simplifies that operational
management the other part is the
security policy so if you ever spun up v
pcs you know that the security policy
typically is constrained to that V PC so
again if you have you know a VP seeing
in the west of V BC in the east of V PC
and amia you're managing separate
security policies for all those V pcs so
if you're a security administrator and
your goal is to sort of unify your
policies of a very uniform policy
applied across many things with maybe
slight tweaks in each of them it becomes
more difficult to manage that uniformity
because they're having to copy and
manage you know 12 15 20 of these things
right in the Google environment because
that V PC can
is global you can really manage one
security policy right so it simplifies
the management of that as well the other
part is flexibility so you can build
exactly what I showed in that first
slide right you could build a regional
VPC construct right and just drop a
subnet in one region and build a second
VPC and drop a subnet another region and
actually connect those with VPNs right
just like you would in a very
traditional model or you can use the
Google model right where you have this
global construct and dropping different
subnets in different regions within that
VPC and you could actually combine them
right you can have some that you're
using that global VPC presence where you
have a lot of subnets and then you could
also be using specific v pcs for
specific applications that are really
constrained to just one region so Google
is really giving you that flexibility
every business is different every
business is unique so what your needs
may be may be different from your
competitors needs or another business
down the street so we've given you that
flexibility to really look at how you
want to use cloud networking and to be
able to apply that in Google's cloud in
a lot of different fashions you didn't
mention just the use case for having
individual subnets in each region so is
that sort of a use case for not using
that global VPC contract so here's a
good your a good use case for not using
the global BBC I was working with a
customer a few weeks ago that had very
specific requirements around the
applications they run have to only live
in that particular region right it's not
necessarily through something like GDP
or other things like that but this is
actual contractual obligations they make
with our customers so while we presented
the idea that they could in theory run a
global V PC and use firewall rules to
constrain what can talk to what they
really didn't like that idea and they
really wanted to create these constrains
network domains so what we ended up with
is actually building you know a V PC and
amia only putting subnets in there and
then for other customers and a pack we
build a completely different V PC and
only put stuff that's in a pack right so
this gave them that very traditional way
of doing things you are sort of losing
that benefit of the simplification yeah
what you'll find in in networking in the
cloud in general is you're always making
constant rate offs right so that's an
example of okay you know for their
particular business they had
requirements they had to meet for their
summers right in terms of contractual
obligations so they they wanted to
really you know manage that expectation
and be able to put that infront of their
customers but they did lose some of the
flexibility here now one of the things
they did do is actually use the global
construct for a lot of common
infrastructure so they could deploy the
application in a V PCE that just lived
in a region but there's a lot of core
infrastructure that they actually used a
global V PC and they tied each of those
regional constructs back to that common
core infrastructure V PC so again
there's that flexibility it's not an
and/or situation right you can use you
know all of these constructs together
yeah not mutually exclusive yep so these
things are really simple to set up I
want to take you through a demo real
quick just to show you exactly how easy
these things are to set up okay so for
those of you have used the Google
console before this is the sort of home
page so what I'm going to do is I've
created a project called cloud cloud on
air networking 101 so this is the
project that I'm in this is the home
page so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
go down to V PC Network click on V PC
networks right now there's nothing in
here I've actually deleted the default
Network what happens when you create a
project is you're actually gonna get a
default V PC that gets created with a
bunch of default networks one of the
best practices is to get rid of that
just just wipe it out in most cases
you're trying to integrate AV PC in the
cloud with some on-prem environment
right so you have a whole IP address
scheme that you've got set up the
defaults generally are not designed to
integrate with what you probably already
have so there's probably some
overlapping space in there so generally
I tell people the best practices just
get rid of the the default V PC so I'm
gonna go in and create a V PC so I'm
gonna call this demo Network you have
custom and automatic subnets automatic
is what I was describing before where it
provisions a whole bunch of ten dot
space for you typically not that used
you typically gonna come in here and use
custom subnet so I'm going to create
Network one here's where you select the
region so this is where that global
construct comes into play right I didn't
create
VPC just in one region now I'm gonna
drop just the subnet into one of these
regions so let's put this one in US
central one let's pick an address block
okay there's a couple other options in
here so private Google access this is
what enables your VMs to actually talk
to Google API is without having to have
a public IP address on them so a lot of
customers don't want any public IP
addresses on their VMs but they still
want to access Google services right so
this could be bigquery this could be you
know Google Cloud Storage bucket scale
all the services that Google has to
offer so if you if you don't have this
turned on you actually have to have a
public IP address because most of those
services you're probably familiar with
rely on public api's right so a best
practice is to turn this on if you were
not to use that option do you have to
have a public IP for the VM that you
deploy yes if you were to not use that
option you have to have a public IP
address on there to say like access your
storage bucket or access bigquery or
access other things okay and for the
forward slash 24 address range is it
possible for you to use overlapping IP
ranges if you were to create two subnets
in one VPC so you can't have overlapping
IPs in one VPC but let's say I created
two separate VPC use I could actually
create exactly duplicate of V pcs I can
have the same addresses and you know V
PCA as I did BBC be now that could cause
problems for you as you go to
interconnect these V PC so if V PCA you
need to talk to V BCB and has
overlapping space now you've got a
problem you can't do that right because
it's gonna not going to know you know
where you want to route this day so
generally speaking you know you're not
gonna have overlapping IP space the same
thing applies to your on-prem
environments or your data centers you're
gonna sort of use separate IP space
typically ten dot spaces what we see in
the cloud environment those same best
practices apply here too yeah okay so
I'm gonna click done on that one and I'm
gonna add another subnet don't spill it
right so I'm gonna create another one
this one I'm gonna drop in uswest
I'll call this one
and again I'm going to turn on private
access I'm gonna turn on flow logs flow
logs are another sort of best practice
flow logs are actually what enable
logging of the actual flows from your
VMs so again if you want to capture
those flow logs you have to enable flow
logging in this environment right but
again it's a best practice to turn it on
so you capture all those flows they get
pushing the stack driver and that you
can use them for troubleshooting you can
use them for a lot of other things if
you're troubleshooting security things
like that I'll talk about this a little
bit next time but I want to talk about
regional versus global routing so in
this environment you can actually set up
your routers to actually just advertise
their routes so the subnet that i'm
created here in the region that the
router lives right so for example i
created one subnet in u.s. central one
if I put a router in u.s. central one
and I had regional checked it would only
advertise the subnets in u.s. central
one right generally speaking what I see
is people using global what that really
means is I could put a cloud router
anywhere in this environment it's gonna
advertise all the subnets in this
environment out to wherever you're
advertising so it could be your on-prem
your data center or things like that
right so again it's another I don't say
best practice there are use cases to use
regional routing but generally speaking
most customers are using global routing
so now I click create and it's gonna go
and create my subnets for me are there
any limitations on the number of V pcs
that you can have in a project or the
number of VMs in a V PC or in a subnet
so let's take it one at a time so number
of V pcs in a project so we have the
concept of quotas and we have the
concept of limits so only touching those
real quick quotas are generally
something that can be increased limits
are something that are generally hard
fixed right so we have a quota for V pcs
where you can put five V pcs per project
now that's a quota right so you can go
and request an increase to that quota to
be able to put more V pcs in that
project you're asking about a number of
VMs and a subnet right every VM is gonna
have an IP address in that subnet so in
this case I created slash 24 subnets so
you're gonna be limited to you know one
IP per VM is gonna dictate how many VMs
you can put in this particular subnet if
I were to make this you know a slash 20
that I can obviously put more the ends
into that subnet okay yeah so there we
go
while while we were talking it created
my two sub that's for me so literally
it's that simple
we just go in there and populate
whatever something that you want this V
PC you drop into whatever regions you
want them in and it Auto creates
everything and I can go and create
compute engine environments create
whatever you need using this IP space so
me go back to the presentation here
okay so I want to expand on the concept
of the V PC so this is something else
that Google is pioneering we call this
the shared V PC so as I talked about
before you build this global V PC
construct to really simplify your
network just simplify your operational
management right shared V PC allows you
to take that simplification even further
so what I'm showing here is this blue
box is actually the V PC that was
created right so there's various subnets
within this blue box right I could have
more blue boxes in this gray box this
gray box is is the project right so when
you use shared V PC projects become two
types of projects you either have host
projects and this is where your network
and resources are actually going to live
so I say networking research as I'm
talking about your cloud routers your
VPN gateways your subnets things like
that are gonna live in the V pcs in that
host project right on the right over
here I have got a few example projects
right so I've got a recommendation
project I've got a personalization
project I've gotten the analytics
project right these are what we call
service projects right so if you think
of the traditional model I would spin
these up as a project I would put the V
pcs in there right so I would have V pcs
in the recommendation project I'd have V
pcs in the personalisation project I'd
have V pcs in the analytics project I'd
have VPN gateways I'd have all the VPN
tunnels I have all the cloud routers I'd
have all this stuff right so this is
sort of that sprawl I was talking about
right so the global construct allowed
you to eliminate some of that right the
shared V PC is gonna allow you to
eliminate even more of that or simplify
your network even further right so in
this example I've got all these subnets
that I've created again in one V PC now
what I'm doing is I'm not actually
creating any V pcs in these projects
right so the recommendation project a
personalization project those actually
don't have any V pcs that are living
within the actual project themselves
right what I'm doing is I'm actually
sharing the network infrastructure from
the blue box that shared V PC into those
projects right so the users of those
projects right they're not creating any
network they're not using a network
that's central to that project are
actually using network from the shared
project right so the way you can think
about is your user is right so a
development team that people is spinning
up VMs and doing operations in these
projects they're touching the VMS in the
small gray box
right like a recommendation project
maybe this is your production
environment right typically the people
that are operating in the blue box are
your network engineering staff right
your network security team they're
managing all of that Network
infrastructure and those are the only
people that are really operating within
that environment so kids are very clean
separation right you don't have a bunch
of hands in there that potentially can
break things or mess things up for you
right
it's just network engineer is just your
security teams right and then they're
pushing that infrastructure out so other
people can actually use it right
so from an iamb perspective this is
giving you that segregation of duty and
correct when you use I am rights right
you're gonna have you know network
administrators you're gonna have you
know network users you have all that
stuff right so most of your network or
infrastructure administrators are gonna
be operating in that blue box right
whereas your users and the guys that are
consuming the network infrastructure by
building VMs by building other sort of
network things they're gonna be in the
recommendation project right so they're
not actually gonna have the ability to
do anything but you know say drop a VM
into that particular subnet they can't
change the subnets they can't you know
create more subnets they can't do any of
that stuff they can only create VMs with
in the subnet that you've given to them
right alongside that kind of idea of
least privilege best practice yep and
then the right side of this drawing I'm
also showing so you've got all those VMs
that have been created off that shared
infrastructure right they're accessing
you know various api's right so I'm
showing a machine learning API Analytics
sort of bigquery API so those VMs are
still able to do that because remember
we set up that Google private access in
the blue box VPC right when we set up
that VPC so all that stuff carries down
to those service projects now the other
thing that's that's really nice about
this is we talked about your your
security domain right we talked about
your unified policy so in this case I'm
writing one policy in that blue box and
when I extend all of those subnets down
to the service projects the security
policy actually goes with them right so
now you've got instead of having to
build all these individual V pcs across
all these different projects you've been
able to centralize your V pcs right you
Mabel - you know centralize your
security policy and now you're able to
scale to hundreds of projects take that
infrastructure push it down to those
projects take that security policy apply
to those projects right and your
security policy you may have specific
rules that apply you know to just the
recommendation project or just the
zatia project or just the analytics
project right but you still only have
one policy that's written in that blue
box right and you're applying certain
parts of that policy and maybe the
analytics project or the personalization
project or the recommendation project
yeah but again when you think about
unifying everything only having to look
at one policy it really simplifies that
yeah especially from a security
perspective and management perspective
and just adding to that scalability yep
so really it sort of continues on that
theme and this is if you take anything
away from today's talk it's really about
how do I simplify my network how do I
simplify the management the operational
day-to-day functions and how can I sort
of use a lot of this flexibility that
Google gives you right whether you
choose you in a very traditional manner
you try to you decide to use some of the
functionality that Google is really
created to really allow you to apply
this stuff right that flexibility is
sort of key and is something that we're
really happy that we can provide so
again simplifying the network right
you're now going to deploy that vbc
across many projects so you could have a
single project with a shared VPC another
single project with a shared BBC but
this allows you'd have just one project
push that said share BBC to hundreds of
them right as we talked about before
fewer networking elements because I'm
building the routers I'm building those
subnets in the host project itself and
in those V pcs again I'm not having a
server that that continued sprawl of
things again I talked about this
simplified management you have one
security policy that you're managing and
you can manage us across hundreds of
projects is there any upper limit on the
number of service projects that you can
have under one shared those project so
there's no hard limit that we've we've
seen so we've tested up to 5,000 right
and it runs fine the quota is a hundred
so you can do a hundred with nothing no
issues no you know not having to come to
Google and request anything special
right but if you want to go beyond 100
projects you have to put in a quota
increase but again in terms of limits
we've tested up to 5,000 we've had no
issues so yeah we don't really
necessarily know how big this thing
could potentially scale all right well
if you have 5,000 projects then you're
in good hands so like it before let me
let me quickly show you how easy it is
to set up just the shared DPC aspect of
things
okay so I'm back into my project where I
built my two subnets I'm gonna go into
under VPC Network I'm actually gonna go
down to shared VPC so this is the menu
when you're actually setting up a shared
VPC and what this piece looks like so on
this first part I'm gonna get to specify
because I'm in this project that's cloud
on air networking 101 project I'm gonna
say yes I want to use this as a host
project right here I can check where
they want to only show shared subnets
are all subnets right and over here I'm
actually going to attach projects to it
right so I'm gonna go ahead and attach a
project so I've created a second project
this cloud on-air 101 shared VPC right
so this is the recipient so this is the
service project that I'm creating now I
defined the host project in that first
tab now I'm defining the service project
so I'll go ahead and click on that here
you have the option to either share all
subnets so I created two subnets in
there one in the US central one in US
West I could just by default share all
subnets right most customers that we
work with are gonna share individual
subnets right so maybe their service
projects are a production project a
development project a testing project
and they have different subnets carved
out so they don't want to share all
subnets with production and all subnets
with testing and all something that's
with dev right so what they're gonna do
is click I want to share individual
subnets so let's say I was using this as
a production environment and I created
my two subnets but I only want to share
one of the subnets so I'm just gonna
click on that save it
really go any Asian there if you don't
want to apply all subnets yeah you can
sort of really get that granular level
you want right again if you want
suffocation you can say I'm gonna you
know apply all subnets if you want sort
of grandly specify things you can do
that too
so again it goes back to that sort of
flexibility the way we've engineered
this is there really be flexible because
as I said earlier every business is
different every sort of networking
construct that we build with different
customers look slightly different right
thing cuz they all have different use
cases okay so now I can go into my
service project so if I go into my
service project
and I click on VPC networks you can see
there's actually no VPC networks I've
created within the service project right
so I haven't done what I did in that
very first step where I've actually
built a V PC I didn't do any of that
right all I did was really go in and
share a subnet with this right so now
you're gonna see these these two options
right so now you're gonna see networks
that are shared with this right so here
you can see that the two networks I have
specified here the both of networks are
showing up but I've actually only shared
one of them so if you go back to the
other environment and they go into the
shared V PCE menu so here it says
network 1 3 users right so 3 users are
all my user identities right even though
network 1 and network 2 were both
showing up under that other V PC I'm
actually shared one all right because I
only see 3 users there right right so if
you look at if you look at this right so
I actually drill down into the actual
shared service the service project right
again you'll see both networks but you
see there's 0 users in there right
because I haven't actually shared that
network so no users can actually
provision any resources in there the
only network or the only sub that they
can provision resources in is this one
right again I could have created 20
subnets shared 15 of them or I could
have created 20 and shared all of them
right yeah it sort of depends on what
your specific needs are and so how
you're architecting the V PC components
of the network so the number of users
you see here is the number that are in
the service project that you've shared
that subnet with correct so that that
service project I have 3 users in that
project right they happen to be all be
my user identities but you could have a
whole ton of users in that project like
your whole development team could be in
there so when you share that resource it
would say maybe you know you're sharing
this with 250 users right that are
authorized to create resources in that
project
so again very simple to set up doesn't
take a lot of time it's it's it's really
designed to be very easy and simple
okay so now let me talk about the VPC
construct in itself and you sort of
built this construct whether you've
built it in a bunch of different V pcs
or you've used sort of Google's global V
PC construct or using the shared DBC
construct right this is stuff that
you've all built in google clouds
environment right so you still need to
connect to it right so this is
connecting from your on-prem environment
or your data center or something like
that right so this is usually the next
logical step of well how do I get
connectivity to all the stuff that I've
built so the easiest way to think about
this is sort of in this cruciform
pattern right so on the left side you
have sort of layers of the OSI model
right so I have sort of layer two
options versus layer three options and
then across the top I have dedicated
options
meaning I'm directly connecting with
Google's edge or I've got shared options
which means I'm connecting to typically
somebody else's Network which is then
multiplexing a bunch of customers
together and then pushing all those
customers that wants up to Google right
so there's there's some other provider
in the middle in that in that sort of
environment and then you've got VPN
which I've sort of put over those top
two so you can't use VPN with layer two
networking options but you're typically
going to use VPN over the top of those
layer three options because most people
as I said earlier are building private
address space in there so let's start
with those top options because that's
typically the way customers start
interacting with Google cloud so there's
two ways that they can sort of do a
layer 3 interconnect when I say layer 3
interconnect I'm basically meaning
they're connecting with our edge at
layer 3 right so you're getting in the
case of dedicated right in the upper
left-hand corner you're actually
connecting to a peering router on
Google's infrastructure and you're
getting all of Google's net blocks
advertised to you right if you go
through the shared route this is
basically using your ISP right Google is
connected to most ISPs globally in the
world we're providing all of googles net
blocks to those ISPs those ISPs are then
advertising them down to you now the big
thing to note here is there is no SLA
around either of these products right so
the layer 3 interconnects no SLA so if
you're planning on using this sort of
connectivity option make sure you have
some sort of redundancy built into it
right connecting into one peering router
and Google directly probably is not the
best architecture if you're concerned
about high availability right so as I
typically customers are building 10 dot
space in their cloud environments right
so that's private address space you
can't advert you can't access that
directly from a public routed edge so
the way that you do that is you build a
VPN over the top of it right so whether
you're using you know your ISP to
connect to Google or you're actually
connecting directly to our layer 3 edge
you're going to typically build a VPN
over the top so this is where you're
going to go and build VPN gateways
within the V pcs that you set up you're
gonna build tunnels to VPN gateways that
you have on pram or in your data center
and that's how you're gonna tunnel
across the public infrastructure all
those private routes right I'll talk a
little bit more next time on the routing
and how this stuff can be built but
suffice to say you're gonna want to set
up some sort of dynamic routing setup
where your advertising subnets across
multiple VPNs or multiple interconnect
methods to give you sort of a high
availability connection right because
again there's no SLA with with these
actual services yeah right now the one
benefit to the layer 3 service is right
now it's it's free of charge you can you
know interconnect to Google's layer 3
edge for no cost right I should note
that if you are doing any dedicated
connections with us whether it's layer 3
or layer 2 everything's done at the 10
gig layer right so if you only need say
500 Meg's or you need a gig or something
like that typically we're gonna push
over to the shared side so it's it's
typically going to be through some
partner interconnect or through your ISP
or something like that so let's move
down the stack to the layer 2 options
these tend to be I would say you know
more preferential these days this is
really about building
so this is really about building a lair
to connection right so these are VLANs
that are being built connect your
environment to Google's environment so
with the dedicated interconnect you're
basically connecting instead of
appearing router you're actually
connecting to appearing fabric right so
this is this is our layer 2 device just
like our peer and routers or layer 3
device that sits on the edge of our
network right so you're gonna build a
physical interconnect to that and then
from that you're gonna provision VLANs
from that edge device to cloud routers
that you build in the VPC construct the
same thing happens on the partner side
in this case you're going to connect to
a partner right Google has a whole list
of partners out there you know a good
example very popular one that we we work
a lot with customers is like Equinix
cloud exchange right lots of people have
presence and Equinix in this case you're
actually connecting to a Kuenn excess
fabric Equinix is fabric is then
connecting directly to our peering
fabrics right but you're still really
going through the same process where you
still have to get VLANs provisions right
so I think that that layer 2
connectivity but again when you think
you and a whole bunch of customers are
connecting to equinoxes peering fabric
Equinix is then doing VLAN segregation
and sending a whole ton of VLANs to are
appearing fabric right so they're
multiplexing a bunch of customers on
that connection when is it necessary for
somebody just like partner interconnect
versus dedicated so there's a couple use
cases here normally there's two real
things right if you think you're gonna
use full 10 gig of connectivity it makes
more sense to go with a dedicated method
versus using shared methodology right
because shared methodology you're
competing with other customers right for
bandwidth right you can't control who is
actually using that bandwidth in any
given time right so if you and I are
both connected to our Equinix and you're
you know sending a massive file the same
time I'm trying to send a massive file
we're basically competing for bandwidth
now we try to engineer with all of our
partners to prevent that from happening
we do a lot of capacity planning to say
you know we should never be above like
50% utilization on these interconnects
right so the chances that happening are
slim but there's also a cost component
too right it tends to be more cost
effective to go in the dedicated side
right if you're gonna use that full 10
gig port then going to the partner side
so there's a couple trade-offs there but
typically if you want something less
than you know full 10 gigs or there's
there some break point it's it's gonna
depend on per partner and where the cost
break-even is so
where the layer three dedicate
interconnects were free the layer two
dedicated interconnects there's a charge
for those right so that's $1,700 a month
per port so you know if you're looking
at a partner version you know Equinix is
gonna charge you something Google's
gonna charge you something at some point
it makes sense just to go to a
dedicating architect yeah are there any
industry best practices that you've
heard of so what I see with a lot of
customers is that they start by turning
up VPNs and then they'll move to like
dedicated interconnector they'll move to
partner interconnect now the great thing
about this is just like the the VPC
construct are not mutually exclusive
right and a best practice that I
definitely recommend is actually using
the VPNs in addition to the dedicate
interconnects so you can start by using
VPN you can actually seamlessly hot cut
over to a dedicate interconnect or a
partner interconnect and your traffic
will actually just flip over right and
then you can leave the VPN as a backup
so if something would ever happen with
your dedicating or connect or your
partner interconnect the traffic will
automatically failover to the VPN it's
since you've already turned it up
anyways and it's up and running why not
just leave it up in place yeah right so
the layer 2 things actually do have an
SLA right so the partner interconnect
the SLA is actually gonna be dependent
on the partner that you choose right
from a dedicated interconnect depending
on the architecture you use is going to
dictate the SLA that you get so if you
connect to two peering fabrics in one
Metro will give you 99.9% uptime SLA if
you connect to two separate peering
fabrics in two separate metros so you
have four connections at that point the
SLA goes up to 99.99% so again depending
on the architecture you choose in terms
of inter connecting to Google there's
going to be an SLA behind it for both
the dedicated interconnect and the
partner interconnects it could be
appropriate for hybrid customers as well
yeah there's a lot of sort of ways you
can mix and match things in this
environment where this typical comes are
more challenging is if you have a hybrid
environment some stuff and say AWS and
some stuff in Google I can't necessarily
connect a dedicated interconnect from
Google to a you know AWS version of this
product right you actually have to have
something in the middle so a lot of
customers will deploy a cabinet with a
router or something like that in Equinix
and then run the connections into that
router and sort of hairpin the traffic
themselves but that actually gives them
a cost advantage versus if they were
just trying to move traffic from AWS to
Google over
public interconnects though that Google
has with AWS that's gonna actually cost
you a lot more money so if you're moving
a lot of data back and forth it's
definitely worth looking at an
architecture where you're bringing you
know our dedicate interconnect service
to AWS equivalent service and landing on
a router somewhere so that's a quick
overview of sort of all the ways that
you can interconnect and how these
things can be used in conjunction to
each other so with that that's sort of a
wrap for today we've covered a bunch of
sort of the foundational stuff thank you
so much Ryan that was super helpful
everyone we're gonna be back in less
than a minute for live Q&A
you
alright let's get started with the first
question so the first one is can I have
a shared V PC that spans across multiple
regions and if so how is that traffic
build ok so remember the V PC container
right automatically is going to span
across multiple regions right so the
first part of that question is yes you
can definitely have a shared V PC
because the shared v bc is just taking
that V PC construct that exists across
all regions and applying it in the model
where it's it's a host it's in a host
project and I'm sharing it to other
things so absolutely you can you can do
that if so how was traffic build traffic
is build at a per project level so when
I'm sharing those resources to another
project and that project is actually
using those resources it's actually
gonna get build from that project right
that I'm sharing it to where the VMS run
because the VMS aren't actually running
in the host project are running in all
those service projects right and the VMS
are what it's creating all the traffic
right so everything's gonna get build
within those service projects and not
necessarily the host project in them
itself okay great in one of your
diagrams you show two VMs in a V PC with
different subnets in two different
regions being able to talk to each other
does this mean that a single V PC is
synonymous with a single broadcast
domain so I wouldn't necessarily think
of it in terms of a broadcast domain
because a broadcast domain is really a
layer to construct right so typically
when you think about a layer to
broadcast domain what's separating
broadcast domains is layer 3 routers
right in this case it's not really a
layer 2 broadcast domain you can almost
think there's one big flat routed
environment right I'll talk about
routing little bit more in the next
cloud on-air that we do but really you
can think about every host is actually a
total router because we program routes
at the VM level so it's almost like this
/ 32 routing domain right there is no
layer to broadcast domain in this
environment right so hopefully that
answers that question
oh can I enforce security policies or
other network related policies on
communication between components in the
same V PC maybe for security policies so
yes you can so within a V PC you're
going to apply firewall rules right so
for example I could have a whole bunch
of subnets in there by default we are
actually going to lock everything down
right
Google generally takes a trust no one
policy right this is all the way we
operate our own internal network right
so we applied this same sort of security
principle in the cloud so for example if
you build a cloud VPC and you build a VM
and you go try to SSH to it you actually
can't SSH to it right you actually open
the firewall rules to enable you know
the certain ports to enable TCP to
enable you know ICMP label SSH all the
stuff has to be opened up everything is
gonna be lock down by default right so
when you set up a VPC and you want to
sort of control what can talk to what
you may build five different subnets
right and you're gonna specify okay I
want only this subnet to talk to only
this other subnet right yeah so you can
sort of create that granularity so I
talked about that one custom that we met
with where they have very specific
regional requirements for their
application right so we presented that
option to them and say you can really
get very granular right so you could
build one big shared bpc and really
build a lot of firewall rules around
that to say you know things in amia
can't talk to subnets in the US or in a
pack right again they decided to go a
different direction and we like being
able to offer that flexibility but you
can definitely get very granular and you
can define things via ports via
protocols via subnets right so the
firewall rules are very granular in
terms of the VPC right so maybe you you
know you don't want to allow UDP traffic
right okay then you don't open it up to
a UDP traffic or you know maybe have
emitter you don't want TCP traffic
you're not gonna have a lot of
communication then but you could
actually lock that off right so you have
that capability to get very granular in
terms of how you write these firewall
rules to regulate what can talk to what
within that VPC construct and the same
thing happens when you talk across
multiple V pcs right you're gonna have
separate security policies in each so
you may connect to VP C's together like
I showed initially in that very
traditional model if you don't open up
the security policies you may have
written security policies in this V PC
to not allow any external IP addresses
to get to it right so you may have
linked them together with a VPN but your
security policies on both sides are not
allowing you to communicate right right
so this goes back to that that
complexity and simplifying right if you
have everything in one you can see one
security policy that you're managing
here
you're trying to manage a security
policy over here and try to manage our
security policy over there
right yeah but the answer the question
yes it's absolutely doable you can be
very granular in this okay depends on
how your requirements go all right we
might have time for one quick last one
is it possible to create a mirror port
in the Google Network of a server to
another server so port mirroring is
something that we're working on it's not
generally available yet but it's
something that we want to we want to
enable as a as a feature so it is it is
a feature request that we have in front
of our product team to say we want to
enable port nearing specific on a large
scale because typically when you get
asked for it a lot of times it's around
security and various other things so
it's something we've asked our product
team to look at to put on the roadmap
but I don't have a specific date on when
port mirroring is going to be available
no worries all right well thank you Ryan
I think that's about all the time we
have thank you everyone for joining us
today please stick around our next
session is protecting your workforce
with a secure endpoints so thank you so
much Ryan once again you bet
you
you